today's topic i disagree with the red
pill community but i 100
understand that there's an absolute need
for it people often complain about like
the rhetoric that comes out of like the
manosphere or whatever and i understand
some of those because
i disagree with a lot of the sentiments
that they share i've been called a blue
pail
and purple pale and whatever the term
that they have
honestly i find the whole matrix
reference is super cringy but it's 100
necessary and i think one thing that
people don't understand
is that there's a lot of expectations
placed on men in regards to
the roles that they have to play in
society in regards to the roles that
they have to play within the dating
sphere
you know the idea that we have to
approach the idea that we have to be the
one putting the foot forward and doing
all this stuff
not saying that women don't have the
responsibilities i'm just saying there's
a lot placed on us right
the big problem is that we have zero
resources in the mainstream
to know how to do these things we don't
learn it from our parents because our
parents
oftentimes don't know what the we don't
learn at school
and our friends are just as clueless as
we are so what ends up happening is that
we look towards media
but the thing is men don't have shows
like the view
men don't have shows like women do where
they get to learn all the next beauty
tips and have all their problems
constantly talked about other than
sports shows
and so what ends up happening is that
men turn
towards alternative media joe rogan joe
oregon is a perfect example of that
he blew up but yo when he was just back
it was just a bunch of guys watching him
all the time because it's like the first
time that they watched someone
speak in long form about that they were
going through i'm talking back in 2013
when this podcast was like
yeah set up right i used to watch it
back down i was like oh okay cool
one thing i've learned like just come to
realize with myself is like i remember
when we first started doing videos i
used to be like
way more angry about a lot of stuff
right and looking back now kind of i
used to ask myself why i was so angry
covering some of these topics
and it dawned on me that for so long
i've been having lived experiences with
women
that were either negative or super toxic
and
when i would bring this up to people
around me they would gaslight me or
they'd be like well as a man that's not
a real thing so
right whether it be being hit whether it
be like women doing weird stuff
saying terrible things and like just the
lack of accountability that society
seems to place on women in those kind of
scenarios
threw me for a loop i couldn't believe
it and so i used to build up a certain
level of resentment to the idea like
they can just get away with this
and that we just constantly reinforce
these ideas right and i would look
towards media and i would watch
you know shows like uh i'm pretty sure
it's the view i can't remember what it
was but a girl just talking about like
cutting off a dude's penis and throwing
in a garbage dispenser everyone laughs
and claps
i don't know the circumstances i don't
know why he filed for divorce i don't
know
what was going on between them however
[Music]
i do think it's quite fabulous i mean
i mean can you just imagine that thing
whizzing around the disposal it's like
hysterical but however i think i would
have just
depending on why she cut it off i mean
it does depend on the reasons why
does it oh yeah
okay she's on the tv for the next couple
like imagine a dude getting
around a round table and everyone
laughing about a girl's like
pieces getting cut off down there never
would happen
and i would constantly see this
reinforcing media where women could
touch dudes grope them do whatever they
want where they can
hit dudes and it's very popular and it's
fine but then
anything that happens to us we're just
supposed to enjoy it because we're men
and
over time i used to get annoyed with
like a lot of the stuff that was just
commonplace and
you know the crazy thing is these women
weren't bad people
they weren't people that were like
extremely malicious
but they're raising an environment
that's told them this kind of stuff is
acceptable
so you're talking about the norm as i
started doing these videos and i started
venting all that pent up resentment all
that anger
coming out i could feel it
all of it just for a period i actually
went to the red pill stuff
i was watching that i think probably
from the ages of like 18 to 25 like
you know because as a young man you're
told you have to do the approach you get
to do all this stuff right
mom i don't know what i'm doing it's
awkward i go up to these ladies and
heart rejections and self-esteem so i'm
like yo i need help so what did i do
pick-up artist i read the book uh the
game i watched uh keys to the vip
which is oddly enough a show that was uh
shut down just for teaching dude's game
right i would watch all these stuff and
i was like cool i'm learning i'm
learning
but they also had some toxic ideas
terrible ideas but i'm like i have no
alternative
where else am i going to learn who's
talking about it who
nobody then i go on youtube find joe
rogan i find
a couple of other red pill folks i'm
like oh okay i'm learning some stuff
but i'm indoctrinating this thing you
know by the time i start 24 25 started
realize some of this stuff is bad and i
took myself
from that environment but i also
recognized it filled a void in my life
that no one else was able to fill there
are
no resources to teach young men these
skills none whatsoever but we expect
them to be good at it it's not
only that is they
expect all these men to do all these
things
and the price for failure is so big
the price of failure not only for your
self-esteem
but just you being labeled a creep
it cost a lot yeah it's really the cost
as well about it i realized i mean one
of my friend realized how much the cost
was
that whenever she was talking that oh
yeah man i was at the i was at the
pharmacy yeah and i saw my boyfriend so
i tap it on the ass
and it was not my boyfriend and i'm like
oops and then i left and my boyfriend
was there and we all laughed and i was
like
if i think i spot my girlfriend turned
in a
public environment i'mma make sure it's
my girlfriend i can't just because i
cannot afford
as a man as a black man to just
tap the booty of just some random girl
nope
and be like oh sorry because the cost of
that
is potentially bigger than just
oops you know jordan peterson comes on
the scene
and he says to men clean your room
and he turns into this huge sensation
and a lot of people just don't
understand especially women they're like
what is so poignant about this
and i'm like do you not recognize that
men were so much in need
of that kind of stuff about telling them
to take responsibility for their own
lives and
how to do it that they turned to just
even that simple piece of advice became
so important do not understand that
there's such a need for dudes
to have their issues suggest it's not to
say that women don't deal with a lot of
terrible stuff
and i agree with you if you want to say
that you are more disadvantaged i would
probably agree with you
but people don't live on a macro scale i
do not live as a black man
thinking about all black people all the
time i'm thinking about my personal
experience as i'm walking through life
so when you go up to a man and you say
your opinions are invalid
and your issues aren't valid because
women suffer more well as an
in on a macro scale i could understand
what you're trying to say
but on a micro scale which is how most
people assimilate their experiences
i'm like well you're just telling me i
don't matter you're telling me my
problems
don't matter so that i'm going to turn
away from you and then
just love to jump in they'll be like we
as a community have created environments
where men stop lying
first off when you go into those
environments they start looking at you
like uh you better keep quiet say only
the right things and say the right way
that's not
inviting that's not appealing so that
men have turned towards men's circles
to find people who understand them and
speak the way that they do
and resonate with their problems so when
you sit there from afar you're like
man this reputable community is trash
well great i think it's great that you
keep saying that but
here's the problem what's the
alternative we can't be on tv talking
about our problems because nobody cares
and we'll get cancelled i've seen
so many men's dude when i was from the
early 2000s to like mid 2010 right
just destroyed and taken off the air
because they were toxic and unacceptable
right but women's tv shows they can go
on for years they can say the craziest
stuff
the most foul things fine for television
but we have no spaces like that not even
that you didn't present
no alternative i don't believe that it
was for them
to present them but where because they
have their own issues
but when others presented other
alternatives
for other people they got shut down it's
not so much it was
like it's like it was your job to
present something other
no it's like asking for men to present
alternatives for women
no we don't know the reality and you are
better placed to know that
wait what are you talking about derek
jackson
sure but because derek jackson
happened and was in line with what
you're saying you let him slide
right but other people you shut that
down
real quick i don't think that it's for
you to give other alternatives but
whenever that alternative happens
you shut it down and you cancel it and
then it just gets worse
what you do by doing that is that you
create martyrs
and then they get to evolve and to
evolve every time
jordan peterson was getting they tried
to cancel him or they tried to do
something like that or they tried to
shut them down
she gained more power and more people
every time you do that
you're doing a disservice to your own
self yep but whatever
so listen whether you're a woman
whatever like listen it behooves you to
acknowledge the fact that men deal with
problems
all right it does not take away from
your issues it does not mean that you're
invalidated but men are struggling and
suffering from certain things and it's a
hard
there's a hard knock life out there you
know just because we're not as vocal
about it as you guys are we don't talk
about it the same way you do
doesn't mean it's not there it doesn't
mean it's not there even this channel
even this channel all right i don't
think you'd throw us in the red pill
area
but you know we definitely have some
ideas that congregate with them as well
right even this channel do you not
recognize why we got so popular so fast
aside from the fact that we got a decent
commentary
part of it is we filled the void so yeah
as far as like the red pill stuff and
all this whole manuscript and stuff like
that men need their outlets and i'm not
saying it's this is the most positive
one i'm not saying it but until there's
a
until there's resources to tell men how
to do this stuff effectively do it well
until women in society in general starts
and val
stops invalidating what men go through
right we're not going to fix these
issues
we're just not sure it was just not so
it's a it's it's a two thing it's a
two-part thing
it's not getting soft here's why i
disagree
i think men for the first time are like
venting on a loud platform
and very directly and they've been
holding it in for so long
that some of it's very toxic so get it
out
get it all out and then after you've
chilled out we've calmed down and then
you know some of this is taking some
time
that we could breathe and like talk
about it some more and get deeper in
there
right because a lot of these problems
are super valid you know
like i said but you cannot discount all
of it
so um that was my thoughts about the red
pill community people been asking me
about that for a while
i'm glad i went through that phase
because it helped me out and i'm glad i
started doing these videos because i got
to vent that
out because i'm telling you i was made
to feel crazy my whole life
even by other men the other man was like
you're supposed to bear it i'm like why
are we tolerating this
i would never think of like doing that
to somebody else but we as men
and everyone just made me think like yo
it's not important i'm like no this is
real
this is real and when you guys make
people feel
like their things are their problems are
not real they become angry
because their problems on the inside
just fester and i still get it sometimes
you know sometimes i
i talk about these problems and i can
start to
feel again the issues that i had back
then
and it kind of comes out of me and i'm
just like where's this coming from like
i still
i still need more time to get it all out
so yeah once again
i'll just say this to end ladies i
recognize i'll have real problems and
i'll never stop
you know try to defend y'all from those
issues and if i can i want to help you
know
but i think there has to be room for men
to be able to
deal with those issues without everyone
trying to interfere because we just
don't have outlets
not the way y'all do not the way y'all
do and if you don't believe me try to
find
try to find outlets on mainstream media
for men to talk about these stuff
candidly you won't you know where we
turn to
podcasts see pasta
that's what it is that's why there's uh
there's a lot more men podcast than
women that's how this
meme why do man why do men don't deal
with the issues
and but but instead they just do
podcasts because that's the outlet
that's what we can talk it out yeah
podcast is very niche
it's very niche so if it's niche i can
find a group of
niche people that go through the same
that i'm going
and it's free i'm not gonna be you know
i got less chances of less chances of
being cancelled
so that's why they do it yeah yeah so
that's my thoughts on this topic we want
to hear what you guys think you guys
agree disagree
yeah we want to hear all your input on
this ladies special jump in there get in
there
[Music]
foreign